the number of us colonel virus related
deaths now surpassing 2000 doubling in
just two days
there are more than a hundred and twenty
four thousand cases now nationwide this
is Hillary Clinton takes to Twitter to
mock the president's America first
message after the u.s. reached the most
cases in the world tweeting quote he did
promise America first disgusting those
comments not sitting well with
congressman Dan Crenshaw firing right
back on Twitter calling her out for
political opportunism let's bring in
that man right now GOP congressman Dan
Crenshaw House Homeland Security member
former Navy SEAL and author of the
forthcoming new book great one fortitude
American resilience in the era of
outrage Carson we look forward to you to
getting a copy of your book soon comes
out in early April but when you saw that
tweet from Hillary Clinton if there's
one moment and one thing we should be
able to avoid politics on its this and
then she tweets that yeah exactly and
then you mentioned my book one thing I
talked about a lot about in that book is
outraged culture and and there's this
this newfound issue where we find the
worst of each other right and we
question each other's intentions and
that happens all the times in politics
but but now is not the time to do that
there is a pandemic going on and
somebody like Hillary Clinton is so used
to taking political jabs at the
president or her political opponents any
time there's an outcome that is
unfortunate but this isn't the time this
is this is a tragedy for all Americans
for the entire world
and it's just not the time and this is
what worries me about the future is we
have difficult conversations about how
to move from risk containment to risk
mitigation to risk management opening up
society along with the threat of the
pandemic it's going to be easy to take
swipes at each other it's going to be
easy to have very disingenuous
criticisms group of each other and
moralize against each other but we can't
do that we have to do this together
congressman I want to ask you about
Texas because in an attempt to prevent
Texas from becoming the next potential
hot spot for this virus governor Abbott
has required travelers from New York New
Orleans to quarantine what do you make
of that decision listen I think this is
going to be the future and it's it's the
right targeted approach okay we're gonna
be able to use data to see where the
hotspots are and take this
vertical approach and and move away from
the horizontal approach where we
quarantine everybody and we start
looking at who are our most vulnerable
people where are the hot spots as we
ramp up testing we'll have more data to
inform those kind of decisions and this
is going to be on the backs of governors
and mayors and I think this says
something else as Americans we tend to
keep looking to the President to
micromanage our situation that's really
not how our system works it never has
and it never will every city has
different needs every city has different
preferences different problems and
governors and mayor's are really running
this show and I think it would behoove
Americans to understand that a little
bit more and to be looking to their
local officials for how many ventilators
are coming in where's the PPE we keep
looking to the President to do that and
that's that's really not how this works
the federal government is there to
support the efforts of our local
governments congressman I want to ask
you about I mean I don't need to talk to
you about resilience my goodness with
your experience but the president
yesterday I think spoke some words that
really may ignite a fire in some people
feeling anxiety feeling uncomfortable
with what they've got a tough enough
here was the president in Norfolk
yesterday listen to this and I want to
get your reaction the world has
witnessed the unyielding resolve of our
incredible American people we are not
only a country of vast resources we're a
nation of colossal strength towering
spirit soaring patriotism and
exceptional character and you're showing
it to the entire world at this moment
concur now important are words like that
at this time
I think unbelievably important and we
should stop downplaying and criticizing
what we aren't doing it but a lot of
people are stop downplaying and
criticizing the president every time he
does something like this or tries to
give Americans hope or tries to point
out the positive things about what's
going on that's okay let's embrace that
just this once let's embrace some of the
good things happening let's embrace the
fact that our industries have totally
ramped up production of PPE that
factories are totally changing what they
do to make ventilators that that people
are actually coming together and
figuring
what needs to get done doctors are
coming out of retirement
you know we've ramped up testing to an
enormous degree in this country which is
why our cases are so high Hillary
Clinton now let's celebrate this stuff
let's work together let's stop looking
for cheap political potshots to take at
each other and actually get through this
is happy right we are actually
transparent about our numbers because we
don't lie to the people in the world
like the Communist Chinese do and we
have rapidly fished out testing as a
result the numbers are naturally going
to go up you could point that out
without being partisan we've been asking
our viewers all morning long to send in
photos that that motivate and inspire
here's one from Lauren in Texas when I
was sharing with you congressman sending
this one with his dog brandy he vows to
hold this one man and dog parade with
the flag every morning until the crisis
ends and here's one from Eric and Lisa
they say they fly the flag to salute
these wonderful often unrecognized
heroes and Robertsons this photo of the
26 foot flagpole now in front of his
property they say everything in Texas is
bigger and that certainly would apply
there yeah we it is that is true and I
love seeing this kind of stuff this is
exactly what I'm talking about
you know our flag is so important that's
why I hate seeing people destroy it
because this is a symbol that brings us
together it means something to us it's a
symbol of our founding of our of our
history and and of these values that
make us American and those values are
courage and strength and the ability to
overcome anything and so I just love
seeing that stuff great stuff check out
representative Crenshaw's book don't
forget fortitude resilience in the era
of outrage can't wait to check that one
out Thank You congressman for joining us
today thank you sir appreciate it thanks
no thank you